thank you for uh coming and putting on a
brave face i know we're all processing
what happened at the oscars and uh
i just want to say to will smith look um
i got your back bro stay strong
april fools you're a dick
oh wow you're on my side
yes it's april 4th
look i'm not here to humiliate will
smith he gets enough of that at home
but uh
i will say this
every single
person in america this entire week was
talking about nothing but the soccer
punch heard around the world right
so the whole keep my wife's name out of
your mouth thing didn't really work out
can we at least say that
what
and the oscars wow there was more action
in that 10 seconds than the whole three
hours of power of the dog
who would have guessed that the movie
that comes out of the oscars with all
the buzz was g.i jane
uh
and you know
also
i must say
comparing a woman to demi moore looking
her hottest is not exactly the worst
insult i've ever heard in the world
i mean alopecia it's not leukemia okay
alopecia
is when you it's when your hair falls
out
appalachia when your teeth fall out
there are worse things
um
and also
i'm supposed to feel bad for will smith
defending the honor of the woman who was
[ __ ] august alcina i mean
also
the other thing that is very a little
fishy about this is that when chris rock
told the joke you cut to will smith and
he's laughing at the joke
right and then he sees that his wife is
giving him the stink eye
i blame toxic femininity i do i i
so
but
now of course is the controversy on top
of the controversy because the academy
says that they asked will after that to
leave and he refused and then got into a
shoving match with liza minnelli
[Music]
so
i don't know who's lying
but
but the academy academy's getting very
stern now the academy says from now on
they may ban will smith from ever coming
back to the oscars and my question and
what's the punishment
[Applause]
you